[Music]
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man he was a
god after saving planet earth for the
500th time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's your family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take
am i um sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
he's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
you
are not like the other gods have killed
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually great
[Music]
his hands were once used for battle
now they've got humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
exactly who i am
[Music]
i will choose my own path
live in the moment
[Music]
my superhero days are over
[Music]
remember what i told you
[Music]
you ever feel lost
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love
[Music]
not me
what just listening
[Music]
[Music]
you